so we're here today to talk about your
movie Imperial dreams which is
premiering at the Sundance Film Fest
malik it's your debut feature isn't it
tell me a little bit about the
inspiration behind it a couple years ago
I met a young man named baa baa Jones
and he inspired me to kind of look
deeper into his culture and he started
kind of opening up access to his world
and through that process I you know we
kind of fictionalized this story that we
came up with Imperial dreams and over
the course of this process we worked
with a couple different labs with the
Sundance labs and another lab out in
Jerusalem and our group a great group of
producers at super crispy Andrea
Sperling Jonathan Schwartz and Katherine
Fairfax right and we just been
developing it and through the process of
having all these great storytellers
involved we just kind of came up with
this and he can be great cost including
yourself in the film tell me what stage
did you get involved and how did it come
about I was very rarely late in the
casting process and I had been invited
by John to set to have lunch which I
found out was simply a trap because day
later he called and asked me if I wanted
to come and do a role on the movie and I
said yes because it's my friend and I
felt like it was a really poignant and
positive story and I think we don't see
enough positive stories about that area
and about those people that that we're
representing there and I was very happy
to do it and very pleased
you mentioned the positivity that and it
is a different look at in a city life
isn't it is more optimistic it's more
positive how important was that to you
Malik to have that portrayal on the big
screen I think it's the yin and the yang
I think it's important to kind of
portray both of them the darkness and
the light side and you know it's kind of
represented in this father-son story
where it's you know this father at all
cost is trying to pursue positivity for
his son so he doesn't raise him like
kind of like himself so you know it's
for us that was something that was just
as true as to the story now I'm we
talked to you John and Rotimi he played
brother
half-brothers and we're talking about
the kind of obstacles they've
experienced in their own lives to get
what they are as actors because the guys
in the film experience lots of obstacles
that they have to try and get around to
keep positive in life to keep moving
forward don't they I wondered you guys
what kind of obstacles did you face to
get where you are today you know I think
it's any human obstacle I think it's I
don't know if I've had many obstacles my
life has been extremely easy I've been
really lucky
I've never tripped I've never been beat
up I've never lost at anything one
everything I'm kidding I think I think
it's like today with today is the day at
Sundance where it's what's it called
free fail where it's you know you got to
see failure as part of the process and I
think it's just how you kind of just
incorporate that into your process you
know so when something happens it's just
how you respond to it that's a lot of
what this movies about is once he faces
challenges how this character responds
to them I think when it's why a new
system it's brother that you know why
you're so happy why are you think happy
at the moment you know exact same any
things are going wrong for him but he's
still trying to keep positive you know
for himself and his kid as well yeah I
mean it's it's a different kind of
culture where you don't really get to
express yourself too much you know
because you don't want to put that side
of yourself out there because you might
get a little weak or you might you know
you you might you know it's the hardest
part of that culture is a lot of these
young men are kind of not allowed to
express that side of themselves or they
they naturally think they may not win at
something because they're they're always
fighting from you know lower side of
something so it's it's it's it's
interesting dichotomy to kind of like
show in a character kind of fighting
through something constantly it's almost
like a superhero quality that this
character Bambi has where you know he's
constantly fighting and you expect him
to crack and you know he does at times
and it's just for me it's still very
attractive to watch and you know I still
go watch dailies by myself and
it's just watch how about you Nico what
about obstacles you face to get where
you are now successful actresses sing
with one you know very lucky
I'm very blessed to have family that
supported me in my endeavors from the
beginning I was never told to major in
something else in school or have a
fallback and I didn't realize how rare
that was until I spoke to people around
me I saw people sneaking to take theater
classes because their parents wanted
them to take medicine or something so I
think the obstacles are the obstacles of
the business you know what the business
is and how many things are available and
that's the obstacle for for any actor or
any actress it's you know as a female
there are obviously so many less roles
available as a woman of color you can
you can cut that down some more so that
being said it has never deterred me and
it's not something that I think about
when I step into an audition room I step
in to compete with myself and I want to
beat myself we're very competitive
people so our biggest obstacles are our
own ego you know it's that's really
truly the biggest obstacle that you have
in life is um I was trying to conquer
that I mean we could spend our whole
life trying to get above ourselves you
know you know when we're talking about
this mode if you walk into I'll stick in
the audition room if you walk into an
audition room I'm worried about what the
person next to you is doing you've
already defeated yourself that's not an
option you've got to go in there strong
and confident haven't you in yourself
and like you say it's just about beating
yourself rather than somebody else and
now tell me a little bit more about
setting the story cuz obviously it's
based on inspired by someone's real life
but but keeping the story within that
wats area of Los Angeles the people who
don't know it kind of it describe it to
them what it's like I guess it's you
know a low-income neighborhood where the
thing is about Watts is there's not many
jobs out there so it's kind of
you know it's 20 minutes from Hollywood
but there's not a lot of jobs out there
and that's probably the hardest part
there's not a lot of jobs in Nyla's
supermarkets so with that it makes it a
little different culture where to hustle
and get money you kinda have to do
things a little bit differently you know
so you may have a different hustle to
get to like you know feed your family
you may be getting government support
and that kind of changes everything
culturally so you know any any
low-income neighborhood low-income
neighborhood in the world is pretty much
the same where you know people are
surviving and for us it's a little
different we kind of know that
tomorrow's may come for them it's like
it's everything is moment by moment it's
a very reactive culture it's um you know
if you say something I may go grab a gun
because you know that's the way I deal
with it so in that reactive culture it
felt right to keep everything there
because you know that's where the story
takes place and you can how did you find
kind of working kind of getting into
that mindset I spent I only had two days
on set that doesn't lessen you know the
worker or what that is but I actually
spent a lot of time walking around and
it was interesting because there's a
lunch van and on movie sets like you
drive from here to that door basically
they're like are you ready to go okay
get out Thanks so John and I walked to
lunch was about five blocks and people
were concerned that we were walking to
lunch but you know I find that when you
step into a place without stepping into
your other nurse people are likely to
welcome you and you just become a part
of that and you're pleasant and you're
respectful and people people respond to
that and give that back to you often and
so that was what I felt while I was
there and it was interesting a couple
people recognized me but they were just
really respectful of what we were doing
and I think that that the part of that
is people being happy that their own
story is being told
and being told in a way that is
inclusive as opposed to people coming
from the outside and feeling like they
know everything about something so they
don't need any help and they don't need
your your stories because we've got this
story that we're gonna tell so you can
just step over there behind that that
tape and somebody will deal with you
later
that's not the feeling that was on this
set and then I was very thankful for
that because people have to have some
sort of control over their story or it
becomes dangerous and very untrue from
the beginning the the residents inside
the Imperial courts housing project
welcomed us so it was you know it's a
family that's the only way we got to
shoot theirs by them allowing us to have
access and you know while we're shooting
there being just a family it just became
a community of people so you know what
we're thankful to be able to I'll have
them allow us into their homes because
it's not like you're just inside of the
projects we were in their home that they
allowed us to like come in and make the
story apartment they the day that I was
the first thing that I was new shootings
I just came on in yeah just came in and
did their business and came out the
mailman came through in the middle of it
so there was a lot of real life
happening around and within what was
going on and I think that that's really
assistive and you're working also with
two young lads but you hear twins who
play the young son for your son of Bambi
played by John boyega
tell me about casting them and tell me
about working with them with the boys
you know that was probably one of the
biggest curveballs that we had and you
know truth be told I we have a great
team of people that just scoured the
planet you know our casting director Kim
Coleman worked her butt off you know and
just brought in everything available and
we just got really fortunate that these
kids you know were able to do what they
did and then you know our producers you
know is it's we just have a wonderful
team of people so more than anything
it's we've got really
really blessed
those kids were cutest buttons let me
start they're so cute
and were they five yeah and but really
tall so you could forget that they were
five which was interesting you had to
remind yourself they're so tall and the
second day the first day that I was
working with the who okay it was he was
busy you know cuz five-year-olds are
busy he was just moving all the time so
the challenge was getting him ready and
keeping that energy harnessed for when
the work had to be done which I think
everybody on set had a hand in like
everybody was a parent at that time I
don't really do much I just kind of let
you guys the second day I was on set we
were outdoors and I was sitting in the
truck waiting and waiting for them to
set up the shot and I can't remember
which one of them because I didn't know
them long enough to tell them apart
climbed up into the truck and over me
like kids do on you and struggle
struggle struggle and getting
comfortable and finally ended up late
across my lap hand across my head like
this head like this and foot on the
dashboard playing with my ear and
talking to me and I was like I you were
the cutest thing in the world and when a
child chooses you
it's like angels sing yeah you know cuz
they're real truthful when they don't
like somebody so I felt really good
about that and I think it helped with
the next scene when I was actually
taking him away from his father I mean
the special thing about those boys they
both have different personalities but
also they were able to kind of cover a
span of different things that were
needed in the film that I didn't really
think about because you know there's
some exciting stuff that happens in a
story where these kids were able to keep
up with it which I didn't really think
about oh this kid's got to be able to
run that full speed to stay with his dad
and these kids were like Olympic
athletes where the his stride was just
as long as boyega's when you watch them
it just if there was any other kid he
wouldn't been he would had to pick the
kid up and run with him but I mean there
are so many things like little things
that I didn't anticipate that these kids
were able to do they were able to hit
every no which was pretty special you
guys finally what can we look forward to
next to meet review um you know what I
look forward to jumping in to something
for me everything's instinctual so I
just put all my love into something so
I'm for me currently right now I'm just
really putting everything into this
right now I'm going back to Broadway
this spring I'm doing Raisin in the Sun
with um Denzel Washington and Diahann
Carroll and Sophie Okonedo your country
woman and I'm also working on
workshopping a new musical called the
Hamilton mixtape which is about
Alexander Hamilton which doesn't sound
exciting but it really is and I don't
know what's next I have a TV movie
coming out this spring half of a Yellow
Sun is coming out this summer I really
want to be a superhero or villain like
for real I'm ready to fly through the
air and kick someone in the neck I'm not
kidding I might do it at Sundance um I
do it tonight
that's someone who got onto the carpet
second here's the nican only bucks a cow
that's what I would like to do you know
and you know you never know what's going
on in the future but I'm a big JJ Abrams
fan I love Cory Fukunaga who is not a
superhero person but is sort of a
superhero and in film Steve McQueen is a
given I've loved him since Hunger I
think he's just an artist you know and I
look forward to just continuing to be
able to do things that fulfill me
artistically you know we got paid a lot
of money to do this movie but I think
you know it's important to be able to do
things because you want to do them
because they feel good I hope to
continue to be able to be an artistic
performer I hope in the next year that
comes yeah yeah lots of love but I think
it's you know it's important to say that
too because people think that actors do
things for buku dollars every time they
step out of the house sometimes you do
things because they simply move you and
you're lucky enough to have the
and to be able to work with people who
also believe in great art and I hope
that the world and our world here in the
States starts to recognize that great
art needs to be compensated and
supported we need a like a film Council
or something that will continue to be
able to make art instead of solely
supporting something that could have a
sequel or a fifth installment we need to
start to be supportive of stories
because they are moving when a great
place to end it thank you so much for
talking to me together today guys and
lots and lots of low with Imperial
dreams and look forward to seeing all
your future projects thanks
you